dude I was watching have you heard the
show I'd love for us to do it never
happening but I would love to see how
everybody never do
it's called 60 days in No so 60 days in
is a show on Amy where five volunteers
so you could be an actor you could work
for UPS you could work for you could be
a gym teacher five volunteers go into
jail for 60 days undercover yeah we
talked about everything yeah but this
new this new season which just kicked
off two weeks ago this new season
there's a guy he's a Pio so he works in
the prison they put him in holding so
the way it goes right they go here's
your story make sure your story saw
because if they sniff you out you're
pregnant shanked and died so just be
make sure your story's well when you put
you in general population guy goes cool
man
he was the PIO has a whole family goes
you know I sure I know it's like for
them it gives me a perspective because
you know as POS were on the other side I
really want to learn perspective they do
this whole story they put them just it
goes holding then you're in with the
general population he's in holding and
they go here's the emergency sign that
you want out if you do this we we won't
ask questions we take you out of the
whole experiment you're out he's in
there for two hours and goes like this
and the producer here the produce goes
what no he didn't mean to do that
because and they they go they take an
audio what are you doing man we just
started us yeah I can't do it it's not
for me producer goes hey [ __ ] me
wait you haven't been in there and he's
like it's just I thought I could do this
and I can't then he's on the in the bus
and the producer goes you tell
everyone's so disappointed because
there's a lot of effort goes you know
it's appreciators so what happened
exactly thinking yes I was just in there
I thought I could do it and then he
starts crying and he calls his wife yes
I fell and she goes you just I just
talked to his I failed it he's crying
dude I was laughing so hard but also
it's like why the [ __ ] would you do that
yeah for 60 you leave your family
friends there's no
Peyman there's nothing so harry cohn
sixty-day Harry Connick jr. tell me a
story about how he was gonna do a role
as a prisoner so he decided to go out
weekend to Angola no this is after the
Angola which is that prison in well I
think it's Louisiana I mean it is it's
the farm they did a documentary called
the farm it's a hell of a Louisiana
state it's where people get kills
maximum-security prison farm it's it's
not good our modern-day sub modern-day
slavery and he he grew a huge beard now
here's the problem very famous and his
dad is the DA his fat dad is the
district attorney put all those guys in
jail so he's not a tractor with a long
beard and a dude comes up to him and
goes sup man there goes a man and Harris
Harris Creighton so time and yeah and
and and pretty big actually here's about
205 okay six-two okay and here he goes
hey man how you doing you know trying to
be all that guy goes I know you are your
dad put me away oh oh it's cool though I
got you bro you just walked away they
probably got him out right away not I
don't know I never cuz I last 60 days in
they tell them they go hey man
make sure your story straight cuz if the
inmates sniff out that you're trying to
be a snitch because that's what they do
right they learn all the secrets
then they snitch on them to the the
chief of the staff so he can correct
what's going on how they get drugs and
stuff like that so they tell him dude
make sure your story straight this other
dude he's a Marine marine he's there the
human story he's there for a night this
old head who's been there for six years
some [ __ ] comes out and he has a big
long beard he goes what's up man
they give here's what's up man they're
talking and the old man goes what you in
for man it's his first night what you in
for man
he gives them a feeling I had a DUI but
it's on this military base so I had in
district County so they took me over
here and the old man takes a beat who's
been there so long seen everything goes
yeah DUI on and names the basing in CAS
and they transfer four counties over
here and he was yes that's [ __ ] man
they believe in that you better get your
story straight man you say because
that's useful of [ __ ] and the guy goes
mm-hmm starts crying cuz mm-hmm such
crime goes into a cell he's like [ __ ] oh
it's hurts cry
but the old man like because you know
hey don't cry
oh dude it's so funny but the thing is
is like those real like they know so
don't man just wait hold up you're from
Cossack County yeah that's four counties
away yeah and you're he's TV blue eyes
tell me that that don't I see you guys
that they get your paperwork they get
you all they know they ask for your
paperwork you have to give it to them
it's a sofa I don't know if you're a
snitch they know everything right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]